this super simple hassle-free recipe is  cooked all in one pot start by browning  chunks of lamb in hot olive oil color  and remove then fried onions seasoned  add chopped garlic ground ginger and  coriander a teaspoon of whole cumin  seeds paprika and fennel seeds  a cinnamon stick bay leaf and delicate  strands of saffron then fry to release  all the aromatic flavors next add tomato  puree chunks of sweet potato and the  juicy browned lamb for a sweet note add  plump raisins then cover with stock and  simply leave to simmer for a couple of  hours  delicious eaten straight away but over  time the flavors will develop and  improve when you're ready to serve  simply finish with fresh parsley minimal  preparation and ready when you want it  fantastic Moroccan lamb with sweet  potato and raisin first chopped onions  ginger and fry them in hot olive oil add  cinnamon you want a really wonderful  charred flavor when colored add water to  steam through